Trump voters let's go with this premise
they're illiterate southern rednecks who
couldn't find Ukraine in a man hold on a
second Hillary Clinton didn't lose II
like she lost the election because of
Pennsylvania Wisconsin in Michigan yep
so which idiot needs to read a map Don
Lemon doesn't is used to street view
question of the day first what do you
think is the worst part about the recent
Don Lemon clip for those who haven't
seen it we're gonna show in just a
couple of seconds do you think it's how
smug it is how painfully unfunny it is
how dismissive it is of anyone who might
even disagree with them let alone this
entire swath of flyover America okay
some of you may not have the context I
think most of you do less yesterday
Lester sill unless there we go who is by
the way blacker than Don Lemon No so
yesterday Don Lemon ran a segment where
he had guests M night Shyamalan and
professional asker of questions three
Rick Wilson as they rapidly mock Trump
voters at length he also knows deep in
his heart that Donald Trump couldn't
find Ukraine in a map if you had the
letter U and a picture of an actual
physical crane next to it he knows that
this is you know an administration
defined by ignorance and episode
laughing though that's part with him
playing to their base and playing there
on M night like Regulus Boomer rube demo
that backs Donald Trump that wants to
think that the dog troops are smarter
we're not that from y'all y'all hey
mister just encouraging them now with
your geography in your memos and your
spelling on the show Rogan experience
you know where he just jumps in
dictionaries Wars all those lines on the
map all right only they may lead us
nowhere Ukraine is a keeper how long it
was okay I think I've seen enough you
guys are gonna watch the entirety and I
won't run it on my site
president Trump responded by tweeting
Todd levad the double bed
television with the terrible ratings I
love it yet an exclamation working in
the parentheses out of the parentheses
about this tweet which brings us to this
week's Donald Trump fact check tweet
tweet J Trump Trump fact-checked we back
it is news and don't you forget it's
good really good check here a couple of
statements he made he is correct Don
Lemon has horrible ratings now so there
it's true one for one
we're gonna fact-check though his
previous statement President Trump was
in fact incur I don't know if he was
dishonest or being deliberately
misleading but he wasn't correct Don
Lemon is not the dumbest person on
television that is verifiably Wolf's
lowest score ever on celebrity jeopardy
Blitzer is the joke you and I was being
generous when you're doing pictures like
I get negative 700 negative 4600 why way
more I will get back to this why the
mockery of Donald Trump's voters is so
misguided but but first let's
demonstrate why let me make my case as
to why Don Lemon
[Music]
he's proud of it
so smiling reason number five and I
already want to do this by the way with
Don Lemon because I've been requested to
be on his show and I don't have a
disdain for him sometimes I think of him
as somewhat more moderate until I went
through the archives to create this
segment and now I mean my dislike is
palpable you can tell you know it's
wrong it's wrong to hate you I would
never hate it is sure yes
but the feeling of hating everything
that makes up the fiber of his being is
different soul it's just the rest of it
so it's your or reason number five in
case you've forgotten this his
absolutely terrible performance as a
debate moderator Carson our war
president Trump is pursuing a reelection
strategy based in part on racial
division Khanna me over the president's
bigotry why are you the best candidate
to heal the racial divide that exists in
this country today which has been stoked
by the president's racist rhetoric after
the president's racist tweets attacking
Baltimore and congressman Elijah
Cummings
the mayor of Baltimore slammed the
tweets and said to the president and I
quote here help us send the resources
that we need to rebuild America so what
would you do for Baltimore in other
cities that need help mr. Castro Trump
is a racist be bigoted see prejudice or
D all of the above you have the floor
was it Donald Trump this happened before
Donald Trump's Presidency both Baltimore
was Freddie gray in Ferguson was Michael
Brown this happened under black lives
matter and Barack Obama not bait
moderation which I'm so glad now that
we've seen this because for the longest
time is as you'll see later he tries to
present himself as a down just a
centrist right down the middle a
moderate well thank God that we have
this performance on the record okay
let's go to reason number four this is
something that it requires a little bit
more context but of course Don Lemon has
gone on his show and ad nauseam bashed
president Donald Trump for his I guess
sort of sexual assault come
what if I told you that I have a
secretly recorded tape of him bragging
about sexually assaulting women yeah
well you don't have that tape let's
let's be really clear Trump was and I we
know the tape in question wasn't
thrilled with it for other reasons but
red he's actually talking about a
consensual encounter they let you grab
that now I get it the second part of
that sounds pretty bad
yes practical they let you now let's
compare that this is why it matters to
the sexual assault that Don Lemon
himself allegedly committed budget Li
allegedly committed I'm clear there
half-asian bill we don't know exactly
what that is he didn't say you can
because they allow you to no no he
allegedly bought a man a drink
approached him at a bar when that didn't
work the man rebuffed his advances he
stuck his hands down his own shorts rub
his genitals and then wiped his hands on
the man's nose and mustache aggressively
accompanied with the pick up line have
the bleep button ready do you like or
Wow
I've heard of people being out of touch
with gay culture but their approach
aren't they Wow this is after he bought
the drinks and it was rebuffed cuz I
know that that went a couple of Kosmos
maybe don't loosen the lady up I go Tate
sweat habit I hit the notification belt
hit all notifications if you're watching
on YouTube because descriptions don't
mean a whole lot and do consider joining
my club at Lazarus crater calm slash
Mukul that's what allows this The Daily
Show there's not available on YouTube
all the change reminds on location stuff
please do consider supporting us here's
another reason reason number three why
Don Lemon is a he's a good one he Civ
extra men he said that it wasn't Jesse
small its fault that he went out there
and proactively premeditatedly faked the
hate crime
keep in mind the follow that about to
show you was after it was clear to
everyone that Jesse Smollett had made up
the story not as bad as is as brian
Stelter but getting close in the court
of public opinion jesse has lost he's
lost the fight in the court of public
opinion
lost that because of how and not his
fault maybe people were I don't know
what they were saying to him how maybe
because of his representatives who knows
he went out and he gave the interviews
[Laughter]
that's trying to just sort of gloss over
something and I love that someone call
them up wait wait I think that is the
single video I have laughed the most yet
yes lo it in my chair at home and that
wasn't an actual comedy video was Jesse
small at the police footage of him with
the rope around isn't it when they walk
in yeah it looks like you just pulled a
shoelace off an old pair of Reeboks see
the house that I had it on the Rope for
the cops like you can take that off in
just a smells like well I wanted to keep
it on so like we see we got reason
number two this is uh I think we have
the overlay yeah this was based on the
the reaction about see was Donald Trump
tweeting out the fan house meme yet and
eleven god-loving makan had this on her
okay I don't I hate the idea when people
just do the clickbait was like a
meltdown I mean this seems borderline
like a meltdown over a mean what do we
in junior high school like what the hell
is what is this sir its Twitter who says
junior high look at the prompter broke
every little word continue pausing
continue pausing right well watch this
they get so sincere this is this is
crazy
and Isis literally crazy are you people
insane you people whose you people what
are you are you insane camera they're
like started stopped all the Democrats
do this stupid silly play this stupid
juvenile mean game history won't record
this mean stupid crap okay he's like a
teacher in grade school who's trying to
who doesn't know who committed a crime
and is trying to guilt the students in
the coming Thor this is crazy
you can't shoot you yeah I mean you just
you you go and you steal Julian's red
hots and you and none of you have the
guts to come forward
I can you you okay you you you do that
and you live with the guilt history 101
is making report on every single Donald
Trump change the channel yeah if you
don't like it Don Lemon don't go through
the nine hour daily process of putting
it in your show this is the last reside
s we're down to yeah that's right number
one because all of this is made possible
by the lie and this is emblematic of the
lie that you see from everyone in media
from Chris Cuomo to brian Stelter and
download they all make the same claim
but I want you to hear it straight from
the piece of mouth that Don Lemon is not
partisan or a Democrat I have to
disagree with you I think on this one
the Republicans are on the wrong side of
history and they are the most
hypocritical I'm not a partisan when
people think that I'm some Liberal
Democrat I'm not or I'm some they used
to think I was a conservative Republican
I'm not what mmm okay black hosts on CNN
in New York City Ronald Reagan ban card
[Laughter]
guess is conservative Republican as dot
dead Johnny Mathis on CNN can be I am
NOT a liberal what huh what what are you
talking we just saw and this is the
problem I think with with a lot of these
sort of legacy media outlets they
understand that now they can be called
on it yeah
I am not as though no one will put side
by side as we have done I am NOT a
partisan liberal and so we won't put
that right next to Donald Trump's a
racist how would you fix the racism in
this country with Donald Trump yeah
exactly
there's just such a lack of
accountability because for the longest
time you just had seen it yeah at CNN
and you had network media and then there
was Fox News we sort of lived off in
their own echo chamber now all of this
content can be put in context and put
together so that you could actually make
your own appropriate judgments and by
the way this all goes back to the idea
with again professional asking of
questions three Rick Wilson's and I come
on and Don Lemon where they were talking
about the idiots wouldn't the Donald
Trump voters are morons they wouldn't be
able to spot you crane on a map if it
was you I don't like it I don't like you
and I could hurt you but Trump voters
let's go with this premise they're
illiterate southern rednecks who
couldn't find Ukraine in a minute well
okay that's the idea that was again the
premise I encourage you to go watch the
full clip hold on a second Hillary
Clinton didn't lose II like she lost the
election because of Pennsylvania
Wisconsin in Michigan yep hmm so which
idiot needs to read a map Donna Levin
doesn't need to be just used to street
view really what Oh
MapQuest are you insane
what is this 2004 ridiculous let's talk
about the 88 voters who voted for Donald
Trump we talk about the people who
elected a president who's brought us the
lowest unemployment rate in 50 years
record numbers of workers returning to
the workforce hiatal force participation
rates and by the way worker layoffs at a
20-year lower we talk about the idiots
who voted in the President and
administration that brought with them
policies that led to the highest median
household income from middle
middle-class families ever by the way
it's a $5,000 since Donald Trump is
become president compare that to only
$1,000 increase under the eight years of
Obama
at what point do you begin giving credit
to Donald Trump as opposed to continuing
the work that Barack Obama did when it
is a five-time increase yeah in a
shorter amount of time the wage growth
by the way just get a ten year high
despite forecasts from people like you
and experts on your show predicting the
exact opposite and it appears that
growth is likely to keep accelerating
again doubt tough 29,000 for the first
time ever in history so I ask you as you
sit there and tell us that this is
ridiculous
and history won't remember the tweets
all we know what may be history well how
about the rest of that who are the real
idiots here what will history remember
because guess what I don't know but it's
not the tweets as well or your stupid
segments or your ever by the way
lowering hairline don't think that we
don't notice difference ago where the
hairline goes up and then plugs and
inspector we get it we know it's
happening you're not pulling a fast one
over on us maybe yet yeah that's right
fly with Wolf's lowest score ever on
celebrity jeopardy wonder but not here
what are you insane ridiculous if you
enjoyed this video subscribe or hit the
notification bell and click all
notifications so that you can be
notified when new videos are PI think
there are videos playing in a box net I
don't care about that I can hear the
ocean in this mug like like like I'm
listening to a two o'clock konk konk
conch is it conch or conch conch conch I
don't know but they really messed up
piggy